there are things that are important for
me to know which is that everybody has
impostor syndrome and if you don't have
it something's wrong with you yeah then
you're a narcissist yeah and i'm a nurse
just happy i don't know there's some
healthy people probably this is what
people in show business always do though
we always go i mean everybody feels
terrible right and then you meet some
healthy people and you're like
so does anything bad happen to you and
they're like not really and you're just
like what i was quite happy as a child
yeah i hate it when i meet someone who's
really funny who was a great athlete oh
i hate that [ __ ] and because i'm just
enraged i'm like no no this is my
consolation prize yeah i got this
because i didn't have any of the other
stuff
and now you're telling me that oh no i
mean i got recruited it was either male
model or um football quarterback and i
decided comedy yeah and uh it's just
gone well ever since i don't want
quarterbacks making callbacks
successfully nicely thank you
i wasn't athletic
that's why i'm able to give you gems
like that
that's a marching band uh side effect i
dislike people who are you know too
happy and healthy and symmetrical and i
do try to dig for uh the tr the trauma
in their childhoods so that i can like
them as people which is my issue and i
know that and we're working through it
in your last special look at you you
talk a lot about
things darker periods of your life
it's probably something if you look at
your trajectory you couldn't have
accessed that stuff earlier on in your
career i know i tried your mom passed
when you were eight
jesus sorry about that that's all right
god damn that has to have had a moment
just a
momentous effect on you oh yeah i think
for sure because anytime you s
succeed in some way you know you get
a conan said or you
get on netflix or or what have you or
even personal things
uh there is a degree of sadness to it
because you go oh man like the person
that you would love to be here isn't
here
and you're like trying to impress
somebody who's doesn't exist anymore
like you don't realize that until you're
older you're like maybe i'm only i do a
joke about it and look at you i'm like
do you think i'd be this successful if i
had a live mom because i really don't
like
i saw my grandma recently and she was
like your mom would think this was so
cool she'd be in the front row and i'm
like i wouldn't be doing this if you
don't think you would be i don't know i
don't know that i would be because i
sort of fell into it
in high school and
maybe i would have but
i don't know i think i probably would
have just ended up being like a drama
teacher or something and
getting married or what i don't know i i
just it's impossible to know but i think
about it a lot where i go oh man it's
not it's so sad that she's not here to
see it but also if she was here my life
would have taken an entirely different
road so
and you have been pretty open about your
mental health
things that you're doing to try and
cope take care of yourself deal with it
which is something we end up talking
about a lot on
this show because oh there we go i
couldn't they were moving the drink away
from me yeah because i kept i kept
hitting it with my hand well also um
we are our main sponsor is an iced tea
oh nice you have a nice coffee
and we're not allowed to ever show or
admit that iced coffee exists oh yeah
and i kept jostling it like a goddamn
unprofessional
child and again
i love that we're in the middle of
talking about this trauma in your
childhood and adam sachs runs over and
moves an iced coffee away from you you
know what it felt like it felt like you
guys were like
you know you're not being that funny and
uh we
we are gonna we're gonna take something
away from you until you you you get back
on track stop talking about your mom
that passed when you ate
we're gonna take this iced coffee away
from you you know this drink is for
winners
we we reward punch lines here at conan
o'brien needs a friend we count the
laughs
and this is a big shock to all of us but
when we got into your mom passing and uh
your mental health struggles
the laugh started to dip
that means no less coffee for you the
levels went down
we are hemorrhaging money right now i
have i'm looking at a stock chart and
we're now a publicly traded podcast
we're bottoming out if you guys could
get back to private jets
they've been mouthing at conan behind me
boring get out of it